la seule constante
et le changement la seule constance et
le changement c'est ce que mon grand
père me disait depuis l'âge de 7 ans la
seule constance et le changement
j'ai jamais j'ai jamais compris cette
phrase mais qu'est ce qui veut dire par
là la seule constance et le changement
en 1991 j'avais 11 ans et je sortais de
chez moi pour aller à l'école et en
sortant de l'école
en sortant de chez moi il ya une grosse
voiture de police qui s'arrête cette
grosse voiture surtout connu sous le nom
de bagues qui s'arrête et trois
policiers sortent de la voiture ils
disent attraper le c'est lui moi moi on
m'a appris quand même en cas de doute
tout court j'ai couru j'ai couru j'ai
couru j'ai couru je suis arrivé à
l'école j'ai réussi à me cacher et m'ont
pas attraper quand je rentrais à la
maison j'ai raconté cette histoire à ma
mère elle m'a dit en bas son père il est
recherché
ils veulent le mettre en prison c'est
compliqué mais ça va s'arranger
à ce moment là a white bihan de match
ma vie a changé pourquoi ma vie a changé
parce que je suis c'était une période où
il ya quelques années mon grand-père
était ministre de l'intérieur
chef de la police à un jour où la police
me courent derrière mais pas pour
rigoler à ce moment là je me suis dit
d'accord maintenant je comprends le sens
du
la seule constante et le changement
parfois dans la vie on sait qui on est
mais on se cherche
ce changement arrive sous différentes
raisons parfois c'est un changement
radical la mort d'un membre de la
famille parfois c'est un proche qui va
en prison
parfois c'est une révolution où tout
change
le changement est quelque chose que tout
le monde cherche mais que tout le monde
appréhende également
c'est quelque chose qui est inévitable
mais en même temps on essaie de le
contrôler qu'est ce que c'est quoi ce
problème du changement
le problème du changement et que au
mieux d'essayer de l'attraper de le
maîtriser de l'anticiper il faut
simplement s'adapter aux changements
c'est à dire quoi c'est à dire il faut
l'accepter et il faut le prendre
quelqu'un comme quelque chose de bien
souvent dans les couples les choses vont
mal pourquoi parce que deux personnes
ont changé en bien ou en mal
chacun décide mais au mieux de
l'accepter de dire on va faire avec et
on va s'adapter
on essaie toujours de le maîtriser quand
j'ai fait mes études en angleterre j'ai
fait des études de droit
j'ai fait ça pourquoi parce que
apparemment c'était les meilleures
études qu'il fallait faire
mais quand j'ai fini ça ne me suis dit
finalement il n'y a rien d'intéressant
oui j'ai changé j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses mais je sentais aucune valeur
ajoutée en moins et je me suis dit je
vais rentrer en tunisie
oui long mais mon père en prison pendant
deux ans et demi oui j'avais un
gouvernement qui était complètement
contre nous mais en même temps on essayé
de changer les choses
le changer un pays on avait beau avoir
tout un gouvernement contre nous mêmes
quand mon père était en prison ils
disaient vous devez rentrer en tunisie
pour construire ce pays si nous si nous
les gens avec une bonne logique
quittons ce pays à qui on va le laisser
donc je suis rentré en tunisie fin 2010
ans en chantant en chantant en 100 ans
ce changement qui allait se passer quand
je suis rentré en tunisie mon frère
également été en prison également pour
des histoires politiques et quand j'ai
et on avait déjà lancé la société wallis
café et on n'avait jamais vendu une
voiture en tunisie
et quand j'ai été voir mon frère en en
parlant aux parloirs disent y est tu
sais quoi
c'est ce qu'on fait c'est pas grave
regarde toi tu est diplômé d'une la plus
grande école hôtelière du monde l'école
hôtelière de lausanne
moi je suis diplômée d'une fac à l'ombre
d'une fac de droit à londres on va une
fois que tu sors chacun fait sa vie à
l'étranger et c'est bon matin at elle
vraiment pas de nous dans ce pays encore
une fois non on lâche rien il est sorti
de prison
mais juste avant de sortir des prisons
il faut savoir quelque chose c'est qu'on
avait créé une voiture tunisienne avec
tout le challenge qu'on a eu c'est à
dire quoi c'est à dire que quand on à
conques en a contacté un grand
constructeur automobile comme peugeot
qui fait 70 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires on avait 24 ans on leur a
demandé est ce que vous pouvez
nous vendre votre mécanique ils sont
bien à a rigolé quand on a été voir
nidal on leur a demandé on voudrait
homologuer un véhicule tunisien pour le
marché tunisien
ils ont dit vous rêvez c'est impossible
on leur a dit pourquoi il a dit parce
qu'il n'y a pas de cahier des charges
c'est à dire quoi c'est à dire qu'il est
quasiment interdit de faire des voitures
en tunisie et les seules voitures qui
vont être vendus en tunisie c'est des
voitures importées la seule normale et
la seule réaction logique de quelqu'un
de 24 ans dire bon ok c'est pas grave on
va faire un tabac walla je vais faire r
+ 4 et et voilà on n'a toujours pas
lâché et là on s'est dit we gonna go
beyond de matrix on va faire quelque
chose que non seulement la tunisie n'a
pas fait mais que les pays arabes et les
pays africains n'ont jamais fait c'est à
dire de faire un véhicule avec le
maximum de taux d'intégration nationale
de l'homologuer au marché européen et de
le vendre partout dans le monde on a
réussit et cet exploit en 2008
en 2009 on avait des voitures qui
roulaient en suisse en suède au brésil
au patin en belgique
quand on a été voir l'administration
tunisienne on leur a dit pourquoi cette
voiture là qui roulent en suisse ne peut
pas rouler en tunisie ils nous ont dit
écoutez on va fermer ce dossier là vous
ne vendrez jamais de voiture en tunisie
c'est clair on a dit ok c'est clair
après 2012 après 2011 et en 2012 on a
fait une deuxième tentative et nantes
une tentative qui a été ce que ça sonne
et on a compris quelque chose que la
seule constante et le changement il faut
toujours persévérer
il faut jamais rien lâcher
que ce soit votre famille votre femme
vos meilleurs amis ou même tout un
gouvernement qui vous dit c'est pas
possible
et bien vous pouvez montrer que c'est
possible comme monsieur le doyen a dit
tout à l'heure
au début on se moque de vous plus on
vous ignorent puis ou vos combats plus
où vous applaudiront vous avez là le
process est la chose la plus importante
vous en tant qu'étudiant vous devez
comprendre quelque chose que vous allez
vers la facilité et le premier la
première raison d'échecs de n'importe
quelle nation on ne pourra jamais être
un état fort et un pays fort si on reste
dépendre des autres c'est à dire quoi ne
pas dépendre des autres c'est d'aller
vers la difficulté c'est d'aller vers le
la persévérance bien sûr que c'est
facile d'importer des d'apporter quoi
que ce soit bien sûr que c'est très
compliqué de concevoir de se faire
moquer d'avoir des commentaires sur
facebook où des gens vous disent c'est
quoi cette voiture là vous devrez faire
mais vous devrez faire faillite vous
devrez aller en prison pour ce que vous
faites bien sûr que c'est difficile
quand votre mère quand vous dites à
votre mère que vous allez faire une
voiture tunisienne vous dit et on me dit
tu as fait tes études en angleterre lrm
chez swiss re pourquoi vous allez faire
une voiture en tunisie
c'est très très très difficile et c'est
très difficile d'aller à l'encontre de
tout le monde mais c'est là vous faites
le changement c'est là où vous où vous
pensez vous êtes quelqu'un de tout petit
rien face à ce gigantisme qui est devant
vous ou vous pouvez faire la différence
toyota en 1920 a dit quelque chose
il a dit il faut arrêter toyota il faut
arrêter d'utiliser
savoir faire et le dur travail des
occidentaux et de commencer à nous prend
à prendre notre avenir en main moi je
pense que un siècle plus tard la tunisie
doit se dire la même chose et la tunisie
quand je dis la tunisie c'est nous vous
c'est pas nos dirigeants c'est nous
c'est nous qui devons nous aller vers ce
changement ou le process du travail
la difficulté on lembras on l'a on l'a
on largue on l'a on la prend avec nous
et on dit c'est vrai c'est difficile
c'est pas facile c'est vrai que
j'aimerais bien commencer mon projet et
rouler en mercedes deux ans plus tard
c'est vrai que j'aimerais bien commencer
mon projet est voué et et et être en
première classe et avoir une belle
montre et avoir de bonnes affaires mais
c'est pas ça le travail et c'est pas ça
la valeur ajoutée mais c'est pas ça la
beauté de la réussite la beauté de la
réussite c'est de pouvoir un jour être
avec ses grands parents avec ses grands
enfants pardon et leur expliquer tout l'
aventure et les choses que vous avez
accompli pour vous et votre pays pour
votre propos pour vos proches et surtout
pour votre communauté
vous savez quand vous mourrez
il ya sur 7 sur cette pierre vous avez
sur votre gauche
la date de votre naissance et sur votre
droite
la date de votre mac de votre mort mais
entre ces deux dates il ya un petit
trait et ce puits tutrice et vous ce
petit trait c'est ce que vos enfants
vont dire de vous c'est ce que les gens
vont dire de vous les probabilités qu'on
soit sur terre sont infimes vous avez
plus de chances de gagner au loto tous
les jours que d'être sur terre que
d'être en vie
donc si vous avez gagné le gros lot le
jackpot
autant faire quelque chose de magnifique
autant faire de quelque chose de
légendaires donc ce petit trait là c'est
vous aujourd'hui qui décidez qu'est ce
qu'ils vont dire de vous est ce qu'ils
vont dire que c'était monsieur lambda
madame linda ou est ce que vont dire ils
ont fait quelque chose de légendaires et
c'est un exemple à suivre et j'espère
que vous serez à leur niveau voilà c'est
dit